so Doug what are we gonna watch today oh
joy of fucking joys
we're gonna watch a movie that I think
both of us promised we would never see
in our goddamn lives for you got to him
it Freddy got fingered promise you swore
you went on the video and said you were
never gonna do this tonight was this one
of the ones I said I would never do I
can't remember I don't care if there's a
video somewhere where I say all these in
the stash skirts I'd never do and I
think it was always under the idea that
a I was wrapping up nostalgia critic and
be like I didn't have any ideas for them
and just when you do it long enough you
get different ideas and what intrigued
me about this I'm not gonna lie I saw
the red letter media review of this and
it's kind of intrigued they acknowledge
it's awful but there is like a strange
artistic trolling is it a where kind of
element to it that I'm a little curious
about there are plenty of awful awful
things I'm curious about I'm still not
gonna do it so you're curious gives a
fuck the only thing should we say the
only thing I know about this movie is
that one scene oh yeah would you like
some sausage daddy would you like some
sausage and he just says Doug I've seen
my nightmare for the next five nights
that's the kind of shit that happens
when you've got like a super cold and
you drink like too much nyquil or
something but Cody minute footage fevers
weird fever dreams yeah that was like
one of the weirdest fever dream things
you could see this is Freddy got
fingered Freddy got fingered
well like the audience got fisted oh
here we have our first line garfield let
himself go
I feel like this is pretty much you age
10 idiot finally gave up on those stupid
dude they're not stupid they're not
stupid whatever pass Thank You ripped
oranges tribute for us so is this after
Zed was retired from the MIB or is this
before he joined this is what kills him
in between men and black to a men in
black 3 at least now that settles it
Portland is the source of all evil there
was a competition have you had just my
life you will not remember to wash your
hands before you eat anything mr. green
that happened we as people let that
happen where do we stop it
I don't know why are we watching it
guess it's just kind of answered
[Music]
what is great great career move number
24 miss Barrymore she so did not need to
make this movie at this time either no
they were married oh I'll give two shits
who drew Barrymore is married to well
she was well out of my league already no
no if she married Tom Green she was
totally in my league so he was robbing
the wallet by marrying her and she was
robbing the trash can like what what you
need here is elevation okay there
actually has to be something that
happens that's actually funny where
these the studio notes yeah I think it's
fascinating to watch a film that clearly
had only one draft it's debatable
whether you could even call that yeah
pretty sure he just took multiple pieces
of paper farted on them and then turn
that in thank God yeah I was really
welcoming that it's like a really bad
game of cards against humanity' with
that one person who doesn't know when to
play the offensive cards so it just
never ends up being funny he's back yeah
I just got it said get inside the care
need to know more about him so he's
going back a real or more about the
character so I'll say this I had to
really think outside the box or some of
these is just like what do you even say
I didn't want to do it yeah it's it's a
challenge it is a challenge just the bad
cavity is what it is hospitals always
this fun no sometimes I'm guys people
and who knows people here die of cancer
that's my kind of humor just darkest
fuck you know what I like about that see
those movies credit she said it very
funny but that's a very easy line to
make funny it's hard to screw up a line
like that so fact this movie didn't I
give credit Wow and let's be honest the
cancer joke is that we're near the most
low grounding in the film yeah think
about that can you imagine the horror of
Tom Green just fiddling around with your
junk that is literally the sir you know
some people eat the placenta we know he
did you found it funny I know does this
offend you as a decent human being no
defense music comedians didn't find it
funny
well that answered that in sorts dr.
Rosen
I'm sure you could just find videos of
this sort of thing on the Internet
yes there's like a dude that's like
finally somebody gets my family's right
after the baby seat dude okay it's your
turn I'm gonna enjoy this I'm gonna give
you a blowjob I know no cane is fucking
ass this I could watch Rip Torn beat the
shit out here all day so there was no
actual script or I think he said write
some words backwards on my head and they
did any gosh you paper he just boom a
it's like movie and that was it there's
I just can't I don't know if it's just
extra stupid or if I secretly admire
that they just completely abandoned the
plot that the movie started out with
there is no animation now there's no
cartoons he has no like literally all
day I don't remember what it was like
what the fuck was the play there's
something about him going to like an
animation see they show the enemies you
see the shows journey and then he's just
back like it's totally gone would you
like a piece of cake for dessert
am I really loud a piece of cake daddy
of course you can have a piece of cake I
don't know what there's something about
the amount of times they repeat stuff
makes me why it's so childish somebody's
a birthday cake yes sir it's my birthday
I almost feel I get the lines not
intended to get a laugh or at least
matter laughs I get the biggest laugh
out of it you're right it kind of makes
me
[Music]
it's only a few seconds but you're right
it's terrifying when I die and finally
go to hell
that's what's gonna greet me that is the
first thing I'm gonna see and I will
know I am in hell pianos like off-key
and it's just like it's it's held like
that is that is the greeting in hell I
had the sausages on my fingers I was
just trying to play the piano
I had the sausages I had the sausage is
it weird sausage as much better off dead
if you removed every single thing that
made that movie funny
yeah you know the Bob Ross talks about
happy little accidents when something is
funny in here it's it's happy cuz it's
funny but it's clearly an accident it's
a happy little accident in the otherwise
unpleasant major train wreck yeah
I lost it down and questioned the movie
I just once it does it feel like what am
I supposed to do with you what what am I
supposed to gain with this information
with what you're giving me help me help
you
you know what make this like a legit
good movie I mean they could at you can
keep things kind of the same but be
attached I can't wait to hear that if it
was if he was the side character and she
was the main character I'd actually
think her story would be a little bit
more he made that it was called drop
dead Fred that's fuckin Fred it's all
about Fred's
fucking up people's vibes isn't it no
well what this scene was just following
her rocket chair and everything and then
Tom Green as the boyfriend just comes
out does that whole scene like that
would actually be kind of like cuz it's
like what is that guy's story it was as
a mental ward or an Institute for
sexually molested children is lonely
what it said
[Music]
okay I'll say this I haven't seen
something in a long time there's made my
jaw drop that was actually like dropped
and that was literal Joshua put in this
I didn't see that that didn't happen
that could know what no no you know what
[Laughter]
like wow let's remind ourselves let us
remind ourselves that there is currently
a major film director who can't direct
the third movie in his series for shit
that's just showing up and this movie
just throws around like who fucking
cares
oh maybe waffles of what the fuck hurry
it I almost don't want to comprehend and
I don't want that to sink I don't want
to think about it but no more secrets
shirt watching a fucking Texas Chainsaw
Massacre
music in the background I'm high I'm
honestly I'm legitimately scared cuz I'm
just like it's still true like let's see
add the enkarans there's still 23
minutes of this movie left and I'm like
what else can they pull up what the fuck
I'm never gonna forget no this is gonna
linger
pollicis this is gonna linger like
literally witnessing a murder just all
this shit is happening you just don't
know what to do or you gotta just laugh
it's like maybe that's this movie's
secret genius you have no alternative
but to laugh like maybe this is world
peace in a movie maybe this is like the
cure for all known disease this isn't a
movie I only laugh because crying would
hurt too much I have no more tears to
shed therefore I can only laugh but
we're laughing this is a Zen Cohen I
feel freedom like there is no there is
no answer to this like only
enlightenment Cohen you think of like
like this this shit about like you know
was the sound of one hand clapping or
there's a duck trapped in the bottle and
you can't break the bottle but you don't
want the duck to die just so what do you
do and you think on it for days and days
and hours and hours just like how
watching this for only an hour and a
half feels like days and days and hours
and hours and weeks and weeks until at
some point your brain stops it just
stops and all of a sudden you're just
like I am Beyond Good and Evil
I am beyond all conceptions I have
achieved Nirvana there is no evil there
is no good there's only Freddie God
thinks and we thought we wouldn't get
anything out of this movie I have now
become a Zen Buddhist a good several
minutes okay you you would read too if
it happened to you
okay good a second route time doesn't
exist there is no ready or not ready
there is no try
do it there was only Freddy got fingered
[Music]
that's hilarious he do for some reason
love it whatever that kid he should have
been Anakin skies have that yellow wind
are there cuz no I feel like I've gotten
back from a long trip of discovery just
in that part I feel like I've done the
hero's journey yeah this would 100% be
on Adult Swim help this would be on Toon
Disney but it could not be in guardians
of the galaxy 3 yeah that's too offense
too far you don't have a mouse in Alice
in Wonderland ease of it the Mad Hatter
and the March Hare is probably normal
Mouse at some point and then they
grabbed him they kept in that little jar
and they drove him insane it's like I'm
one of you now
that's what I feel like this movie is
done I'm like I just I accept I'm one of
you it's called stop dose it's total
Stockholm Syndrome I think the biggest
problem with this film is I could
predict everything that was gonna happen
I mean from the first rave you know
everything that's gonna you know the
order the lines everything from are we
watching this you still know Chad why do
you have to lower yourself to this level
you did cuz a house a step up
[Music]
[Laughter]
he drugged her it's like the end of
Hannibal no you don't get a hug outta me
buddy
you get shit for this huh
I'm sorry Big Ben I'm terrified beyond
the capacity for rational thought feel
easier to get through the mama Mia but
not by much I feel like somehow I've
come out more powerful for having
survived this but yeah I am equated it
to having your best friend that is my
metaphor for this movie or losing an arm
or being caught in some horrific
accident I'm out of coffee I'm out of
brain and I think we need booze after
this yeah
you